hello everyone we are pleased to have
you join us for cardinal health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast managing laboratory
utilization i am bob ordered of lab
roots i'll be your moderator for today's
webinar we are delighted to bring you
this educational with seminar presented
by lab roots and sponsored by the
american society for clinical laboratory
science the mission of the ACLS AF CLS
i'm sorry is to make a positive impact
in health care through leadership there
will a sugar excellence in the practice
of laboratory medicine for more
information please visit a spls borg we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem to the green Q&A button on the
lower left following this presentation
head over to the community of learning
in the lab exchange lobby to have the
opportunity to engage in live chat and
have more of your question answered on
the spot about managing laboratory
utilization I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Rick canning
rick is a senior administrative director
of laboratory services as health
partners and park nicolay in minneapolis
minnesota he has been involved in a
variety of laboratory management
positions for over 30 years rick has
been a member of the clinical lab
management association
since 1984 and served out of state
president in 1990 throughout his career
is also actively served a sels in a
variety of positions most recently as
the chair of the Advanced Management
Institute planning committee rick is
also concentrated on process improvement
lean and Six Sigma laboratory
standardization and integration
professional advocacy and utilization
management please join me in welcoming
Rick to today's event I will now turn
the presentation over to him thank you
very much Bob for today's session we're
going to be talking about managing
laboratory utilization and just as a
heads up we're going to concentrate on
utilization of laboratory testing and I
say that just because we could also be
talking about utilization of blood
products or blood management that will
not be one of the topics of idiot of
today but some of the concepts will be
similar so to get us started some of the
objectives for today are to talk about
appropriate utilization of lab testing
and the development of lab tests
formulary how to use information
technology to enable appropriate
utilization of lab testing and then some
of some strategies that we will discuss
various strategies that can help address
lab test utilization just also give you
a little bit of background some of this
comes from work that I'm currently doing
in my current organization some of it
has come from my previous organization
which was at Fairview health services
here in Minneapolis Minnesota and then
some of it has also been for my doctoral
studies so the movie had the topics i'm
going to summarize today have to do with
how do you establish the utilization
management committee talk about
duplicate testing and its role in
utilization management the development
of a test formulary utilization of
testing algorithms how to use data data
is very key in this whole process and
how to use data how
use tools in the electronic medical
record and then a project that I'm
currently working on was it which is
genetic testing utilization in our
organization the next slide is just a
cartoon and basically the doctor is
telling the patient all your labs are
back they show a serious overuse of
unnecessary and inappropriate tests and
procedures and obviously that that's the
issue that we're trying to address here
and there actually should be a third
word introduced into that cartoon but we
we need to talk about unnecessary or
over utilization we need to talk about
appropriateness and we also need to talk
about underutilization because sometimes
doing more lab tests would be the better
thing to do in terms of cost containment
and better diagnosis and treatment so
just a little bit of background why why
is this topic so important we need to do
this because it's an important patient
safety strategy in our healthcare
systems doing unnecessary testing is not
the right thing to do for patients and
does not add to a more safe patient
environment we need to perform the right
testing on the right patient at the
right time I'm sure you've heard that
phrase many many times but it is really
key to anything that that we talk about
when we talk about laboratory test
utilization and by doing the appropriate
laboratory testing at the appropriate
time we can avoid avoid doing more
expensive tests and more expensive
procedures and exams because lab testing
as all of this in the industry know is
one of the most highly valued resources
in healthcare for relatively low cost
you can get a big bang for your buck lab
testing even though you know we have
very high volumes of lab testing in this
country with over five billion lab tests
performed every year and it's the single
highest volume activity in the
healthcare environment there was a study
done by Beth Israel back in 2013 which
looked at a very high volume of
Dolph from for 46 of medicines 50 most
commonly ordered lab tests and what they
found is that about thirty percent of
all tests were probably unnecessary even
more surprising the results suggested
that equally as many tests should have
been ordered that weren't ordered but
basically there's a thirty percent
overall rate of test overuse in this
country and a similar rate of under use
now this slide I know is a little bit
blurry as you look at it but you don't
need to be able to read much on here
other than looking at that the one red
line which kind of separates itself from
that tangled web of other lines on the
graph and this is looking over a period
from the early 1980s until the current
time and looking the red line is the
United States and all that other tangled
masses everybody else and basically that
healthcare spending in this country as a
percentage of our total economy or as a
percentage of the gross domestic product
has risen steadily and pretty
dramatically over these years and is now
at about eighteen percent of our economy
much higher and growing at a much faster
rate than the rest of the industrialized
world so we do have a problem and I
don't have a graph of this but we could
also show you a companion graph which
doesn't necessarily show just because
we're spending more that we have higher
quality than these other countries and
then the other issue which comes more
pertinent pertinent in today's
environment is that we are shifting from
a and a paradigm of talking about volume
and paying for volume and paying for how
many we did of something to paying for
the value that we derive or paying for
the outcomes so we're making that shift
from cost quality from volume to value
and at all links in with the Triple Aim
of improving patient experience
improving population health and
decreasing the cost of health care so
there have been many many approaches
that have been tried for this strategy
of addressing utilization some of them
have been
your educational in nature the challenge
is you can't get to everybody
communications are not always read in
general there tends to be poor
compliance with the communications that
are used re-education how frequently do
you need to provide this information how
do you deal with the fact of that influx
of residents and fellows that changes
every year just intercepting those
orders as inappropriate once you
accession them it requires a very
time-consuming process of communicating
with physicians inner get acting with
physicians you're doing it after the
fact you're not doing it real time
you're responding to something you're
reacting to something requires a lot of
professionalism on the part of
laboratory professionals requires some
very high level communication skills and
unfortunately the specimen by then has
already been drawn and you're doing a
lot of backtracking what are some of the
issues in our environment our that
everything that's going on around us
that impact utilization and imprint
impact the practice of laboratory
medicine so we've had probably a very
high level of implementation of
computerized physician order entry cpoe
there's a lot of clinical decision
support tools that are available to us
especially in our electronic medical
records in our laboratory systems
therefore is an opportunity for us to
interact with the decision maker at the
time of the order and help direct
decisions in the right direction but you
have to balance that with the fact that
we even though we have all these tools
over use of the tools can be quite a
dissatisfied for our users i er
physicians and other providers you've
all heard of pop-up fatigue probably in
in the electronic medical record and if
you over use these pop-ups they tend to
just get it ignored they're a
dissatisfied and they actually tick
people off the whole concept of
Meaningful Use has entered into this and
then as I've already mentioned the whole
paradigm shift from volume 2
this is another way to look at why do we
have all these utilization issues and
it's multifactorial we have providers we
have the clinical labs themselves we
have the patients we have the health
systems that in each of these areas
there are a number of factors so I'm
just going to mention one here as an
example let's talk about the providers
let's talk about the physicians the
people ordering the test you have to
realize the reality of their practice
these days it's very complicated and
there's a lot on their plates and they
have to keep a lot in mind when they're
treating their patients there's truly a
knowledge gap laboratory testing is
changing significantly and worse in an
especially high level rate of change
time in laboratory medicine when there's
many many new tests and a lot of genetic
tests and for a provider to keep up with
all of that is almost impossible and of
course they're hip from various
directions with a variety of marketing
about all these new tests and why they
should use XYZ test versus ABC test
there's the fear of litigation so
therefore that can tend to lead to over
ordering and then sometimes there are
financial incentives to do so in each of
these areas there are multiple factors
that are all leading to inappropriate
utilization of laboratory resources this
talks about one of those factors related
to the providers and this shows us in
the United States if you survey all the
medical schools and they had a plot of
forty-six percent response rate in this
survey it shows you how much time was
spent on training and education in
laboratory medicine for residents and
medical students and as you can see it
varies from less than 20 hours in some
medical schools to a maximum of 61 to 80
hours but that's in a very low number of
medical schools most of them are in that
21 to 40 hours and then secondarily
maybe in the 40 to 60 hours so very
little time is spent on this
topic and again in a in an era when this
is changing so rapidly and dynamically
it's really challenging for physicians
to keep up with it now i shamelessly
have borrowed this diagram from a RUP
laboratories in Salt Lake City this is
kind of a roadmap for what are the
various components of utilization
management and it starts obviously with
a concept at the left to very effective
utilization management at the right but
the various components are analytics
governance when we talk about governance
it has to do with the committee
structure and how do we manage this the
analytics has to do with the data but
then the policies that you have the
formulary that you develop how you
implement it how you maintain it so
we're going to kind of follow this as we
go through some of the strategies that
we're going to talk about so data
analysis or the edel analytics and here
i put in this quote you've got to know
know what you're running away from and
also what you're running toward what are
you trying to achieve what are you
trying to fix running away is not
necessarily a strategy you need to know
where you're trying to go and what
you're trying to achieve why do you need
data why can't we just do it often one
of the reasons you need to do that is
you need to make the case you're either
making the case to the physicians and
the providers you're making the case for
supportive utilization management to
your administration order your finance
officers you need data to make the case
and to help you visualize where you're
starting and where you have the
opportunity to go to our stakeholders
need to understand that inappropriate
utilization is problematic vault over
utilization and under utilization we
need to raise awareness and we need to
define the issue again more about why we
need data we need to understand where
we're going we need to understand what
true north is what is the direction and
what is the ultimate outcome that we're
trying to achieve again we're trying to
convince people in the c-suite
we need to measure the value of what we
do both in terms of clinical cost of the
patient cost of the laboratory cost of
the health care system the impact on
what we do and then we need to also be
able to publicize that value first and
foremost what is the value clinically
but also there will be a related
financial value also a data alone does
not achieve what we need to achieve you
need action you need change and that's
what will result in performance
improvement so here are just some
examples and these come from a variety
of sources but data can come from
databases and tools that organizations
such as the University Health consortium
might have or many of you do
benchmarking in a product called action
I oh and so therefore you have an
operational database or you may belong
to the premier organization and they
have tools or there are basic
benchmarking tools out there from
organizations like chi or your reference
labs for example from a RUP but then you
need to layer on top of that everything
related to change how do you propose to
change how do you network and talk about
the change how do you have helped people
adopt two new best practices and how do
you just manage the change process in
and of itself because that is difficult
people don't like to do that inertia
kinda wants to prevent them from doing
that so again we need to understand the
impact of over utilization and under
utilization and inappropriate pneus
again both financially and from a
quality point of view we need to measure
our progress if we start to make changes
we need to know where we started and
then monitor the improvement or
sometimes unfortunately the lack of
improvement and then we also want to be
able to compare ourselves into benchmark
with similar organizations to really
look at are we trying are we able to
achieve best practice or improved
practice many organizations when they do
this set a goal maybe in the
benchmarking you're trying to be top
quartile
the last organization I worked in and in
the 1 i'm in now our goal is usually to
be top decile the top 10% but you need
to kind of know where you're starting
and ultimately what you're trying to
achieve unfortunately and I don't have
this on the slide some organizations use
this inappropriately and actually take
the benchmarking numbers and apply it to
you before you're able to make change
and it becomes your target or your
budget which is very inappropriate and
almost impossible to achieve sources of
caste utilization and I'll use my
current organization Health Partners in
park nicollet the reason there's two
names there's we are a merger of two
organizations that came together about
two years ago this is the third year of
that combination or that relationship
and this year I'm relatively new in my
job and just in the fourth month of my
position the lab integration part of
that is now underway so we have various
sources we have our lab information
systems unfortunately we have two of
them at this moment sunquest on one side
of the organization and soft on the
other side we have an electronic medical
record fortunately there we're both
using the same product currently
different versions and are currently in
an integration project to bring those
together a year from now we use decision
support systems and we are we use the
advisory board quite a bit and a product
that they use called crimson again
because we're coming together we have
two different primary reference logs
which will change over time but
currently will be using both a RUP and
one organization and quest in the other
and then we use a variety of tools and
have a variety of tools available to us
University Health consortium because one
of our hospitals is a member of that we
have premier as one of our sides of the
organization is a premier member the
other side is innovation member we have
access to the tools that Kai solutions
has available and then we are using the
resources of a rup to help us with our
with both our reference lab but also to
look at things like outreach and
utilization so each in your own
organization you have hopefully a
variety of resources that are available
to you and a variety of sources of data
that are available to you just to give
you an example of some benchmarking so
this is an example for my previous job
where initially the target that we were
trying to set for ourselves was to be at
the 25th percentile the top quartile
ultimately that was revised to try to be
in the top decile what you see here is
my lab or the place that I was we were
starting at the 50th percentile so we
weren't by any means the worst your we
were average we were kind of in the
middle and then if you compare to
specific organizations that I've made
them generic for the use of this we were
comparing anything from people in the
30s you know so in the lower part of
that two people at the 90th percentile I
have that backwards the way this one
words 90th would be actually on the low
end thirty-eight percent would be on the
better in and then if you look at pure
numbers our lab so i'll pick one of the
labs that was at fairview we were
actually at the 67th percentile again
the higher that percentile in this
product the lower your performances so
you want to be in a lower number and
versus the higher number we weren't that
far from the 25th percentile when we
adjusted that to the 10th percentile we
had much more of a change to make one of
the tools we use is to monitor send out
testing look at the shifts of volume
look at the shifts and test mix we try
to do that on a regular basis compare
last year to this year what has changed
what is increased dramatically what is
it what is decreased dramatically has
the total volume increased as the
expense changed dramatically so maybe
our volume stayed the same but the mix
of expensive tests changed so really
trying to take a deep dive look at
your send out testing and see what
opportunities you have to try to address
some of those utilization issues and
many of our really good reference labs
do a nice job of trying to bring those
things to our attention even though it
might drive work away from them they're
trying to provide us a service and help
us address test utilization another way
to look at this is we can hopefully
start to look at what test should we be
doing in-house ourselves versus
continuing to send out to a reference
lab I have these this last slide in this
slide slightly out of order because this
again goes back to look at benchmarking
and again what you see is this is
measuring bill tests in a variety of
ways so bill tests / cute discharge
build test for acute patient a acute as
our lab test versus discharge adjusted
discharge for complexity or adjusted
patient day based on complexity and
again looking at where you are we are
lab X what is our percentile rank again
a lower number is better what is the
25th percentile so we kind of seed 25th
and where we might have the opportunity
to move to so for example of a look at
the second line inpatient build test per
patient day we are at the 40th
percentile but the 25th percentiles at
seven we're way off on a patient day
perspective and so again how you look at
your data how you pick your targets is
very very important so just using
impatient test utilization because
that's what that last slide was about
and when I was at my previous position
that is where we started to look at
inpatient utilization and for us at the
University of Minnesota impatient
utilization was about half of all the
testing done in the laboratories on that
campus so you need to kind of start with
that broad high-level look
at your utilization and one strategy
again there's many many strategies here
but is to look at it on a DRG basis
which dr g's and we did it in other jobs
have done similar things with blood
management which dr g's are the biggest
consumers of your product whether it be
lab testing whether it be blood products
and really trying to kind of narrow down
your focus so you're not trying to boil
the ocean so to speak so look at all lab
testing by dr g and then you can dig
deeper into that maybe you've identified
your top 20 drgs and start to look at it
by service by physician you can dig even
deeper and look at it by specific tests
and you can dig even deeper depending on
your data sources by what are the
outcomes what is the length of stay what
is the cost again you you need to start
at the top at a high level look and then
keep digging deeper to help help you
define your strategies this is a very
hard slide to read but it's looking at
that saying what are the top ms-drgs in
my system and in this case 20 ERG
category is accounted for forty three
percent of all test utilization in this
institution so this is a way to start
because you can address a significant
amount of your utilization by focusing
in on these DRG categories and then you
can start to look and do some comparison
again it just depends on your data
sources this happens to be from the UHC
University Health consortium but in
various areas I could look at how I
compared in the upper left-hand corner
for example heart transplant lower
left-hand corner liver transplant and
then various categories of drgs and
where was I looking at tests per case
versus where was somebody else again you
have that opportunity to compare to a
group you can compare to specific people
in the group but trying to get that let
that high level look at where do we
pair with the people we want to be
compared to moving on a bit one of the
key aspects for utilization management
is to really have a structure an ongoing
project or process around utilization
management and a key piece of that
becomes the utilization management
committee with goals to you know to look
at optimizing your utilization for your
patience reducing unnecessary testing
and therefore reducing costs trying to
get best practice and so again depending
on where you are and what sources of
data and what benchmarking you have you
know set some best practice targets for
yourself improve appropriateness by
using evidence-based best practice
protocols provide consultative guidance
to the physicians and the residents to
help them order the right tests we'll
talk about some aspects of this as we go
through this when you form the
utilization management committee you
want to make sure you have the right
people at the table a bias of mine and
if you look in the literature this tends
to be true it's not always successful if
it's if it's a top-down administration
downward type of thing or even if it's a
lab to physician type of thing it needs
to be collaborative and it's usually
more successful if the physicians or the
providers themselves are helping to lead
lead that process and then the lab can
facilitate that process make sure you
have high level leadership support your
CEO your chief operating officer your
chief financial officer whatever it be
it's important for this to be an
important priority of this of your
organization make sure your process is
open and transparent and in that it's
multidisciplinary its key key key HS
emphasize it enough that information
technology is key to the success of this
there's an opportunity to use tools that
help your process so you need active
support participation in partnership
focus on patient care does practice cost
reduction will happen but don't make
that be the focus of why you're starting
and where
you're going that will happen if you do
this properly and then you have to
remember to monitor and report and that
helps build your credibility it helps
build support for the next thing you
want to tackle and to make sure you
share your successes and celebrate them
so examples these are just examples
again they come from my previous
position because I'm relatively new in
this position we developed alerts in our
epic electronic medical record system to
help us address duplicate testing and I
keep in touch with the people there and
I know that just recently they've
implemented one of these develop we
developed a partnership with our
reference lab so that's one thing i'd
always recommend and look at what
resources are available to you to help
you because there are people out there
who've done some of this and whether
it's through networking that you talk to
other people or you use organizations
that you already have relationships with
it can be very helpful and for fairview
a RUP was going to help them develop a
formulary add genetic counselors support
to help you review all those expensive
molecular and genetic test orders so
this was in the process of occurring
right as i left fairview but as I'm now
in Health Partners and park nicollet we
have recently hired two genetic
counselors that will be based in the
laboratory one of them started two weeks
ago and the other one starts next Monday
and i'll be talking about genetic
testing at the end but if this this in
itself is a key component to our
strategy we work with our benchmarking
are our performance data analysis
program in the case of fairview that at
the university that was University
Health consortium we worked with the
residency program and actually they
reached out to us they wanted to make
their residents more aware of pricing
and cost when they ordered tests and if
anybody ever comes and asks you that
don't please don't avoid that question
and ignore it because it's a great
opportunity communication is important
and then ultimately developing sometimes
developing physician report cards
he'll compare performance laboratory
tests formulary which is one component
we're all familiar with formularies in
the pharmacy world it's basically a
utilization device where you can help
focus on things that you allow to be
ordered usually things that you make
more difficult to order things that you
don't allow to be ordered and it's been
done for years and years in pharmacy and
now it's becoming more and more common
in the laboratory we want to make it
easier for clinicians to order the right
tests and hard for them to order the
wrong tests we usually do it on a
criteria based or a tier sort of
structure if a test really only needs to
be ordered by a small group of specific
physicians then you restrict it to that
small group of physicians and don't
allow other people to order those tests
and an example of a tiered process could
be a test that anybody can order a test
that only specific specialists can order
more tests that maybe require further
approval before they can be ordered by
anybody and that could be a genetic
counselor that proves that a department
head proves that a pathologist approves
it testing algorithms are another tool
in the toolkit of test utilization these
are all about best practice and
evidence-based testing protocols usually
they're disease-specific there are tons
and tons of examples of these in the
literature whether they're from mayo or
a RUP or academic health centers people
all over the country have implemented
these types of protocols and you don't
need to create them from scratch there's
different types of algorithms there's
some of them RIT driven where there's
clinical input and information but then
you are able to program it and have it
the function based on the IT system some
are laboratory driven apologists driven
genetic counselor driven there can be
different types of algorithms that you
can use to look at testing so in a
variety of organizations I've worked for
duplicate testing
to be a significant issue that
contributes to over use of testing and
inappropriate use and a waste of money
sometimes it's due to the the misuse of
your electronic medical record and the
misuse of physician order entry there's
functionality that exists in those
systems but physicians don't always use
them I'm finding just in the
organization I mean with now it's more
in a problem in one half of organization
but they found a way in the other half
of the organization to make those tools
more they force them a little bit more
so that they're used properly when you
have multiple positions on the same case
that can often result in duplicate
testing overuse and abuse of standing
orders and the fact that standing orders
can stay open forever can sometimes lead
to overuse of lab testing defensive
medicine we don't want to be sued we
want to make sure we cover all our bases
we order everything when you have
residents in an academic setting that
can often or result in over ordering or
just the fact that your test catalogs
and the names of your tests and the
descriptions are confusing can lead to a
fair amount of miss utilization or
inappropriate some strategies for this
you can build rules in your electronic
medical record we use the phrases soft
stop and hard stop a soft stop is just
when something pops up and tells you
something it hopes you do the right
thing a hard stop makes you do the right
thing it doesn't allow you to proceed if
you've done something that you're not
supposed to education is part of it but
it can't be the only piece limiting the
time frames on your standing orders
cleaning up your test catalog and then
reviewing the physician and specialists
favorite favorite lists in your
electronic medical record we find that
you know your epic system or whatever
your electronic medical record gets set
up and then you're up and live on it for
years and years and you never go back
and take a fresh look at those those
frequent ordered lists or those favorite
lists and a lot of times the misuse
because those have not been adjusted
this talks about that soft stop vs hard
stop if you want a good resource there's
a lot in the literature from the
Cleveland Clinic has been a lot of work
in this regard and they did a lot of
studies and found that there was not a
lot of value when you just did a soft
stopped because it didn't force you to
do anything and if anything it just
annoyed doctors because all these things
popped up so you got this pop-up fatigue
and they just ignore it they don't read
it they bypass it it really they did
this they tried it it ultimately showed
them that they needed something firmer
and like I said in my previous
organization this soft stop technology
has recently been put in place for some
duplicate testing and it'll I'll be
interested to watch them and see if it's
successful or not this is very hard to
read it i guess it's harder to read than
i thought it was going to be but this is
a slide in this example of what
Cleveland Clinic did because they
ultimately did a hard stop and the
success of their hard stop was they
looked up testing and they started with
testing and they started with a short
list of tests that should never be
ordered more than once in a day or once
in 24 hours on an impatient ultimately
that got expanded to more than once in a
stay and maybe more than once in your
life because there are certain tests
like genetic tests that no deep don't
need to be ordered more than once in
your life but when one of those tests is
ordered this pops up and it basically
tells you this has already been ordered
so if we're talking about once in 24
hours they tried to order the test
hemoglobin a1c in this case you find out
it was already ordered in the previous
24 hours but not only do we just tell
you that we give you the result and we
tell you who ordered it and we tell you
when so and usually then that just stops
the whole process but this is a hard
stop they literally can't continue
without making a phone call to somebody
and maybe there's some special cause or
special reason
but this just stops them they can't
proceed in this case now we wanted to do
this at fairview but we just got pushed
back from our IT department even though
the physicians supported it we couldn't
get the IT department to do it now
Cleveland Clinic which is also an epic
they just did their own custom
programming that fear view they were not
not willing to do custom programming for
us hard stop you can do various
scenarios i've already talked about this
once in 24 hours once in an inpatient
stay once in a lifetime this sort of an
example of being the initial shortlist
that Cleveland Clinic did dr. Gary
Prokop is the person who has been very
very involved with this at the Cleveland
Clinic and has written about it and
talked about it so this was a short list
of tests that they decided to try as
their pilot ultimately they continued
with all these tests and ultimately
expanded beyond this list but they ended
up taking uric acid off because they
found there were certain patients
especially patients with certain
chemotherapy where it was appropriate to
do it more than once in 24 hours
duplicate testing alerts that's one kind
of what we just talked about other
places have done this example here
University of Mississippi Medical Center
it monitors things like CBC's and basic
metabolic panels it looks at tests that
are ordered duplicate within a four hour
period again they did a strategy they
put something in place and they saved
just on this strategy 146 thousand
dollars genetic testing so I told you to
talk about genetic testing specifically
it's a major effort and I'm deeply
involved with now in my new organization
and one of the things you need to
understand about the organization and in
now it's not only a provider of
healthcare and we have hospitals and
clinics but we are also a payer health
partners is one of the major players in
the state of Minnesota so we're able to
look at this both from what will we pay
or what will we approve and then also
from the clinical side about what what
we will do so genetic testing this is
increasing pretty dramatically euro
year-over-year twenty to twenty-five
percent it now accounts for about
fifteen percent of all laboratory costs
and is anticipated to reach about a
quarter of all lab costs again it talks
about the increase that talks about the
cost and I kind of duplicated myself
there by saying the same thing twice
sorry about that current situation in
our organization based on the year 2013
we were spending about 6.4 million
dollars in the Health Partners side and
about 1 million on Park Nicollet and
some of the other components of our
organization the risk projection that
that that was done so that there's going
to be about a fifteen percent annual
volume increase and that the misuse or
overuse of these tests is about at a
level of thirty percent and you'll see
that thirty percent being pretty common
if you look at various things in the
literature what reference labs tell you
there's an organization out in Seattle
called plugs that looks at lab tests
utilization and thirty percent is the
pretty common number and then that
thirty percent is a combination of
things that just shouldn't be ordered at
all or things that were just
inappropriately ordered and need to be
changed this affects all aspects of care
it's a predictive its diagnostic it's
therapeutic you get into germline
furniture no formal pharmacogenomics
genetics and tumor markers the scope of
genetic testing there's a variety of
aspects to this there's a rapid rapid
pace of new tests coming on the market
it's very complex it's very difficult to
keep up with it all there's a growing
number of multi gene testing panels that
are available on the market often
there's limited evidence of clinical
utility for these things they're more
and more interestingly enough
limited access to genetic counselors
we're seeing that in parts of the
Minneapolis st. Paul area were access to
genetic counselors isn't nearly what it
should be and then you have a unique
coding that goes with all of this which
makes the billing of it very complex but
it all leads to the cost and the
experience that we have with genetic
testing obviously this is all related to
the Triple Aim of evidence of
evidence-based quality care exceptional
experience for our patients and
affordability for our patient and I've
listed some other points here you know
affordability over in the lower
right-hand corner we talked a lot in our
organization about the total cost of
care and really pay a lot of attention
to that you know you can read these
bullet points yourself but all of this
does relate it to the Triple Aim and the
model that we're putting together if you
start at the top this is all about
knowledge management how do we manage
this ever-changing Dade daily change in
what the what the environment is in this
what the landscape is in this because
the testing keeps changing there's new
tests all the time so part of our
structure is we're going to be looking
for a software product to support us
where there's companies out there that
try to keep up with all of this so that
we don't have to try to keep up with all
of it ourselves we have we have a data
source that we can go to expert panels
so when we're considering whether we
should allow performance and payment for
different tests will put expert panels
of physicians from a specific specialty
together and we've decided both
physicians from our organization and
because we're a pair and pay we pay
multiple organizations we need to have
experts and physicians from other
organizations also and then developing a
genetic testing database then we kind of
split off into two things what do we do
on the care side the provider side and
what do we do on the plans side or the
payer side of this so on the care side
it's things like informed consent how do
we use epic as decision support how do
we use epic as ordering and process
support
we code and bill where do we send these
things to what are the labs we're going
to use on the planned side of the payer
side how do we provide information to
our members how do we how do we develop
coverage policies how do we deal with
prior notification and preauthorization
how do we added claims what are our
contracting and payment strategies so
this is the model that we are in the
beginning stages of in our organization
some of our current strategies are we've
developed a genetic testing committee
structure there's an Operations
Committee steering committee and kind of
a day-to-day lead committee I happen to
be on the lead committee which kind of
is driving some of this we have hired
two genetic counselors I've already
talked to you about that they work very
closely with our send out coordinators
that each site they review all genetic
test orders they determine the
appropriateness and approve modify or
delete orders communicate with
physicians review the medical record
they're really concentrating on on lab
test orders and right now they're
process is somewhat complicated due to
IT issues over time we will address
those they help us assure that informed
consent has happened and they
investigate the appropriate place to
send this testing to performing expert
panels already talked about that we have
started to develop two formulary
committees payer formulary committee and
then on the care side of provider
formulary committee we have entered into
a membership with the plugs program the
utilization program that started with
dr. my Caspian at Seattle Children's
Hospital and they do more than just
pediatrics they're a great resource for
us and then right now we're in the
process of evaluating these different
software systems and we have an RFP that
will be going out so that we can select
the appropriate tool for us to use back
to the genetic counselors our first
genetic counselor for the lab these are
people they don't do counseling with
patients per se because we have other
genetic health
does that do that these are lab based
and they're really reviewing the orders
and help us do the appropriate orders we
already have saved thousands of dollars
in just the last two weeks with our
first genetic counselor with just crop
things that are just stupid in some
cases and inappropriate we've cancelled
things that we've changed things she's
had very good conversations with
physicians and already in two weeks now
physicians are starting to call her so
it's been a good change for us what are
the keys to success in genetic testing
needs to be multidisciplinary you need
to be an open transparent collaborative
process focused on patient care
evidence-based reporting a results
leadership sponsorship this is not
unique to genetic this is this is for
everything related to utilization
management so I actually have a little
bit faster than I thought I would so we
now have time before we go to kind of a
question the community we have time for
people to submit questions that I could
answer during the remaining time yeah
well thank you Rick for that informative
presentation I'm thrilled to be a part
of cardinal call flat exchange before we
get started on the question answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
they can submit questions by typing them
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can we do have a
question here now and take this is
regarding the duplicate tests alerts
jeans got at sonora Regional Medical
Center asks is the 146 thousand dollars
saved the cost of the tests are the
charge for the test that's a very good
question and it actually is and the best
way to measure this this is actually the
cost that was saved the charges would be
obviously much much more and I really
don't mean a whole lot but this is
actually the cost of what that testing
would have been
believe in the case of the example I
gave you was the direct cost so it
didn't have indirect costs in it but it
was the direct cost of doing the testing
well well thank you rhythm either we'll
wait a second to see if any more
questions come in in the meantime I
would like to thank our sponsor ascl s
for making today's educational gasp
possible and after the after we're done
here and we'll let you know encourage
everyone to go to the community of
learning following this presentation to
have the opportunity to engage in chat
with with Rick panning and your peers as
well as you know get answers to bring
questions you may have in regard to
managing laboratory utilization so here
is another question has come in this is
from to excuse me teri Allah Reynolds
Memorial Hospital how did you get the
physicians to buy into the algorithms
for ordering laboratory testing oh you
know that is a challenge and that again
is a very good question and that's
that's why I often in these you know as
we set up our governance structure and
we set up our committee structure you
need to involve physicians from the
beginning similar thing holds true for
blood management when you're trying to
make changes in the way they use blood
products and you need to involve them so
if your algorithm has to do with a
specific specialty or if it's across
specialties you make sure you include
physicians as you either develop that
algorithm or as you review an algorithm
that you have found from another
organization you need to need to involve
them in the process and try to get those
people who are thought leaders as
physicians within your organization so
that they can then pass it on to their
peers and really show that there there's
buy-in and to support that so it has to
all do with the collaboration and the
communication and the involvement from
the beginning
you just have to kind of build that that
trust okay our next question and i hope
i pronounced it correctly this is on
Ziemer at the co2 dupree health care how
many evidence-based order sets do you
have in place okay so I'm not going to
be able to give you a number in my
current organization because I'm
relatively new that number is relatively
small at this point and we're currently
working with our formulary committee
which is primarily composed of
physicians with a variety of specialties
and our expert panels to help us develop
more of them right now we're in a
situation an organization that the
profits to do that and get them
implemented into epic is going to be
relatively small for the next year slow
for the next year because we're in that
integration process of trying to
integrate our two epic systems it'll be
part of the enhancement or optimization
afterwards with the intent of building
more of these but there are a few of
them built now that some of them are the
common ones like thyroid celiac disease
those types of things which have been
built and were built early on so we're
somewhat in the infancy of that process
well thanks again Rick and again that
thanks to everyone for the questions and
I would in like to encourage everyone to
go to the community of learning you know
to have to talk further with Rick about
managing laboratory utilization and I'd
like to remind everyone that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through October this year you
will receive an email from laboratory
you when this webcast will be available
for replay when we invite you to forward
that announcement to your colleagues who
may have this today's live event thank
you very much and until next time
goodbye